let's practise applying patterns. Remember the HomeworkScores class from before,
here's a slightly modified version of it. We had it collect all of the scores,
so that we could do competitions with them later. But if all that we want is to
add all of the scores in and calculate the total without the lowest one, we
don't need to collect of the scores. So, here's the outline of what we want to
build. A HomeworkScores class with an addScore method and a getTotal excluding
lowest method. The only method that should be a mutator is the addScore method.
In earlier lessons, we had a method for removing the minimum score. But in this
version we wont remove any. We will just find a way to no to count them when we
are calculating the total. There are few corner cases I'd like you to think
about, they have special behavior. If there are no scores yet, say that the
total is 0. If there is one score, say the total is that score. If there are
more, say the total is the total excluding the lowest. Now remember, I'd like
you to do this without collecting all of the scores in an array list, or an
array. Try this yourself. And if you'd like a hint, there will be hint links
over here. They'll show you more videos.